economía en directo américa de france 24
y ya está conmigo en el estudio daniela
blandón dan y empezamos una nueva semana
con noticias poco alentadoras porque los
mercados reaccionaron negativamente todo
en rojo como lo estábamos adelantando al
dato de inflación en eeuu hablaron muy
buenos días y feliz lunes para usted el
índice de precios en eeuu recordemos en
los últimos 12 meses que terminaron en
mayo subió 86 por ciento este es un dato
no visto en 40 años y sustancialmente
mayor al que esperaban los mercados esa
inflación al rojo vivo aumentó las
preocupaciones sobre un endurecimiento
más agresivo de la política monetaria en
una semana que es decisiva para los
bancos centrales entre ellos la reserva
federal es decir raúl que puedan subir
todavía más las tasas de interés este
dato del viernes fue difícil de digerir
para los inversionistas que salieron a
vender sus activos de riesgo y se
refugian entonces ahora en otros como el
dólar por eso es que se está
fortaleciendo esta moneda a nivel
mundial el bitcoin
de casi un 10% la jornada de hoy por
debajo de los 24.000 dólares a mínimos
de 19 meses que aunque no es una moneda
comparable pues es una cripto moneda si
refleja el ánimo de los inversionistas
las que si son monedas rivales como el
euro o la libra esterlina también el
franco suizo están en mínimos de un mes
y el yen japonés está en su nivel más
bajo desde 1998 escuchamos que piensa el
gobierno
subo a front event de los 2000 subte es
importante que las tasas de cambios se
muevan de manera estable y reflejen los
fundamentos pero recientemente ha habido
fuertes caídas del yen y estamos
preocupados por eso el gobierno
continuará trabajando en estrecha
colaboración con el banco de japón y se
mantendrá en guardia prestando mucha
atención a los movimientos de la moneda
y su impacto en la economía y en los
precios al consumidor
y ante todo esto dani le pregunto como
amanecieron entonces las bolsas del
mundo
raw las acciones mundiales sobre todo
las asiáticas cayeron hacia nuevos
mínimos de 2022 siguiendo los pasos de
wall street el viernes que se desplomó
esta medida pues que los inversionistas
se hacen a la idea de que va a haber un
menor crecimiento global y mayor
inflación las plazas bursátiles europeas
son un mar rojo el día de hoy a mitad de
jornada por quinto día consecutivo con
índices que caen más del 2% esta es una
gran semana para los bancos centrales
como lo decía porque la fe también el
banco de inglaterra y el banco nacional
suizo tienen sus reuniones de política
monetaria veremos qué pasa bueno y
alemania- de eeuu ponen la lupa sobre
las gasolineras anne y así es raúl el
vicecanciller de alemania está
proponiendo que la agencia antimonopolio
de ese país tome medidas drásticas
contra las compañías petroleras y esto
por qué porque desde el primero de junio
entró en vigor un recorte en los
impuestos a los combustibles que al
principio se notó pero ya no se está
notando y los precios en las bombas de
gasolina siguen siendo altos varios
políticos han acusado a las petroleras
de utilizar esta medida para llenarse
los bolsillos los aliados del canciller
olaf scholz han propuesto cobrar
impuestos a las ganancias extras de
estas empresas como ya lo han hecho y lo
han gestionado a otros países como reino
unido pero uno de los partidos de la
coalición rechaza esta iniciativa ocurre
algo similar en eeuu raúl en donde el
galón de gasolina está en un máximo
promedio de más de 5 dólares casi el
triple de los menos de 2 dólares que
costaba hace apenas un año el presidente
joe biden puso su dedo acusador sobre
exxonmobil una de las petroleras más
grandes del mundo y dijo estaba
manteniendo sus niveles de producción de
gasolina bajos para mantener altos los
precios y disparar sus beneficios
sexualmente lo que dijo fue que exxon
raúl este año ha tenido más beneficios
que dios mismo
daniela que nos trae como cifra el día
buena o mala mala raúl mire 25 millones
de toneladas de granos atrapados en
puertos clave de ucrania por culpa de la
guerra esto lo recordó la organización
mundial del comercio que inició el
domingo su reunión de más alto nivel en
cuatro años que esta semana aglutina a
120 ministros de países miembros en
ginebra y justamente los temas en la
agenda son la inseguridad alimentaria
por la guerra las vacunas contra el cob
y de 19 y la sobrepesca todo lo que hace
una guerra daniela muchísimas gracias
como siempre por toda la información más
adelante nos vemos con más economía y
nosotros vamos directo hasta bruselas
para hablar con nuestra corresponsal y
seré herrera